It's not an accident that the axiomatic
western individual as someone who was
unfairly nailed to a cross and tortured,
it's like,
yes.
Right.
Exactly.
So what do you do about that?
Well,
I thought about that for a long time
too.
It's like,
well,
you don't get together and a damn bb
because all that does is allow you to be
as horrible as you could possibly
imagine in suffer from none of the
consequences.
That's a bad idea.
So how about we don't do that?
Well,
there's a deep Heidi in the west too.
It's like,
pick up your damn suffering.
And Barrett,
I try to be a good person.
So you don't make it worse.
Well,
that's a truth.
You know,
I read a lot about the terrible things
that people have done to each other.
You just cannot even imagine it so
awful.
So you don't want to be someone like
that.
No.
Do you have a reason to be?
Yes.
You have a lots of reasons to be God.
There's reasons to be resentful about
your existence.
Everyone you know is gonna die.
You know you too.
And there's going to be a fair bit of
pain along the way and lots of it's
going to be unfair.
It's like,
yeah,
no wonder you're resentful.
It's like acted out and see what
happens.
You make everything you're complaining
about infinitely worse.
There's this idea that hell is a
bottomless pit and that's because no
matter how bad it is,
some stupid son of a bitch,
like you could figure out a way to make
it a lot worse.
So you think,
well,
what do you do about that?
While you accept it,
that's what life is like.
It's suffering.
That's what the religious people have
always said,
life is suffering.
Yes.
Well,
who wants to admit that?
just think about it.
Well,
so what do you do in the face of that
suffering?
Trying to reduce it.
Start with yourself.
What good are you?
Get yourself together for Christ's sake
so that when your father dies,
you're not wining away in a corner and
you can help plan the funeral and you
can stand up solidly so that people can
rely on you.
That's better.
It will be a damn victim.
You're a victim.
Jesus obviously
put yourself together and then maybe if
you put yourself together,
you know how to do that.
You know what's wrong with you.
If you'll admit it,
you know there's a few things you could
like Polish up a little bit that you
might even be able to manage.
You're insufficient present condition
and so you might shine yourself up a
little bit and then your eyes will be a
little more open.
Then you can try and yourself up a
little bit more and then maybe you could
bring your family together instead of
having them be the hateful,
spiteful,
neurotic in fighting batch that you're
doomed to spend Christmas with.
So when you fix yourself a little bit
kind of humbly because you don't go on,
you're a fixer upper.
If there ever was one and then you got
to figure out,
well,
but can you figure out how to make peace
with your idiot brother?
And probably not because he's just as
dumb as you.
So the holiday hell are you gonna manage
that and so then you maybe you get
somewhere that way and your family sort
of functioning and you find out,
well that kind of relieved a little bit
of suffering,
although it reduced the opportunities
for spiteful revenge and that's kind of
a pain in the neck and so then you get
your family together a little bit and
your little clued in.
Then at least a bit because you've done
something difficult that's actually
difficult.
You're a little wiser and so then maybe
you could put a tend to do finger out
beyond the family and try to change some
little thing without wrecking it.
It's like our society is complex and we
teach our students that they could just
fix it.
It's like go fix a military helicopter
and see how far you get with that.
It's like you're already going to dude.
You're like a chimp with a wrench.
Whack.
Oh look,
it's better.
It's like,
no,
it's not better.
Things are complicated and to fix things
is really hard and you have to be like a
golden tool to fix things and you're
not.
So,
and that's the other message of the
West.
It's like how do you overcome the
suffering of the of life?
And I'm not saying it's only the message
of the West.
How do you overcome the suffering of
life has been a better person.
That's how you do it.
Well,
that's hard.
It takes responsibility and I think you
know,
if you said to someone,
you want to have a meaningful life,
everything you do matters.
That's the definition of a meaningful
life,
but everything you do matters,
it's going to have to carry that with
you.
Or do you want to just forget about the
whole meaning thing and then you don't
have any responsibility because who the
hell cares and you can wander through
life doing whatever you want,
gratifying,
impulsive desires for how useful that's
going to be and you're stuck in
meaninglessness,
but you don't have any responsibility.
Which one do you want?
Well,
ask yourself which one are you pursuing?
And you'll find very rapidly that it
isn't the majority of your soul that's
pursuing the whole meaning thing because
well look what you have to do to do
that.
Yeah.
Have to take on the fact that life is
suffering and you have put yourself
together in the face of that.
Well,
that's hard.
Christ.
It's amazing.
People can even do it.
I'm stunned every day when I go outside
and it isn't a route a riot with
everything burning.
You can really.
God,
you talked to people.
It's like I knew this guy.
He'd been in a motorcycle accident and
it really ruined him and he was like a
linesman,
you know,
working on the power and he was working
with someone who had Parkinson's disease
and they had complimentary inadequacies
and so two of them could do the job of
one person and so they're out there
fixing power lines in the freezing cold
despite the fact that one was three
quarters erect with motorcycle accident.
The other one had Parkinson's.
It's like that's how our civilization
works.
It's like there's all these ruled people
out there.
They've got problems like you can't
believe off.
They go to work and do things they don't
even like and look,
the lights are on.
My God.
It's unbelievable.
It's,
it's a miracle.
It's a miracle and we're so ungrateful.
College students,
the postmodern types,
they're so ungrateful,
you know,
they don't know that they're surrounded
by just a bloody miracle.
It's a miracle that all this stuff
works,
but all you crazy chimpanzees that don't
know each other can sit in the same room
for two hours,
sweltering away without tearing each
other apart because that's what chimps
do.
So
anyways,
so what happened?
Well,
I made some videos and I got to the
bottom of some things at least as far as
I can tell.
So I told you what the bottom is and
then I got this idea about what you
might do about it,
which isn't my idea.
It's like it's not my idea.
It's an old,
old,
old idea.
It's far older than Christianity.
It's old.
It's the oldest story of mankind.
Get yourself together,
transcend your suffering.
See if you can be some kind of hero.
Make the suffering in the world less.
Well,
that's the way forward as far as I can
tell,
if there is any way forward.
Knots,
what's under assault by the
postmodernists,
so look out because they know exactly
what they're doing and they know exactly
why they're doing it.